He's looking at the microphone with awe, just like his father, a natural-born podcaster. He's just drawn to the microphone. You drop down into Codex, boom. In fact, when I installed the Macchi for the first time on my workstation, I've got like two different GPUs, one on the motherboard, which is like a really old Pascal P620 GPU, and then I've got a Quadro RTX, which is still pretty old. It's like a Turing GPU. It got confused somehow, tried to hook up to the QuadroRT.
他正敬畏地看着麦克风，就像他父亲一样，是个天生的播客主。他就是被麦克风吸引了。你进入Codex，砰。事实上，当我第一次在工作站上安装Omachi时，我有两块不同的GPU，一块在主板上，是那种非常老旧的Pascal P620 GPU，然后我还有一块Quadro RTX，也相当老了。它就像是一块Turing GPU。它不知怎么搞混了，试图连接到Quadro RT。
TX 8,000, and then, like, ended up just like the GUI wouldn't open. So you're in TTI land, which is, like, honestly, when you're dealing with Nvidia drivers, if you've been doing this for the last decade, it's a normal thing. But guess what? Omachi has Codex built in from scratch. You drop down into codex. It took me, like, a couple minutes to realize I could do that. And then it's got three different sign-in methods.
TX 8000，然后结果就是图形界面打不开了。所以你就进入了TTY模式，老实说，当你处理Nvidia驱动程序时，如果你过去十年一直都在做这个，这是很正常的事情。但你猜怎么着？Omachi内置了从零开始构建的Codex。你进入Codex。我花了大概几分钟才意识到我可以这样做。而且它有三种不同的登录方式。
Even though I'm in, like, TTY land, I don't need a browser. You can sign in from another device. I sign it from the other device. And then, boom, I got codex. I've got some driver issues solved for me. I was thinking about... Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 306, recorded on September 30th, 2026. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce.
即使我处于TTY模式，我也不需要浏览器。你可以从另一台设备登录。我从另一台设备登录。然后，砰，我就有了Codex。我解决了一些驱动程序问题。我当时在想……欢迎来到ADSP播客，第306集，录制于2026年9月30日。我叫Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Bryce在一起。
We chat about Omachi, Linux versus Windows, Codex, and more. So you're on, you're on childcare today? No, no, because of the recording. I guess I should talk into this if we're going to release this part of it. Seeing as we're doing this recording, I told Shima, I could take this. a baby for 10 minutes because he was being pretty fussy downstairs. Would you like to say anything to all the podcast people? He's looking at the microphone with awe, just like his father, a natural-born podcaster.
我们聊聊Omachi、Linux与Windows、Codex等等。所以你今天在照顾孩子？不，不，因为要录音。我想如果我们要发布这部分内容，我应该对着这个说话。既然我们在录音，我告诉Shima，我可以带十分钟孩子，因为他在楼下一直很闹腾。你想对所有播客听众说点什么吗？他正敬畏地看着麦克风，就像他父亲一样，是个天生的播客主。
He's just drawn to the microphone. I think he's probably actually mesmerized by the four monitors and AI's running in a couple of them. We got audacity running in one. You know, I've always been a one monitor. I've got to tell you. And the reason is sometimes I've been like a one big monitor, but it's just like focus. Like I'm an easily distracted person.
他就是被麦克风吸引了。我想他可能实际上是被那四台显示器迷住了，其中几台还在运行AI。我们有一台在运行Audacity。你知道，我一直是个单显示器用户。我得告诉你。原因是有时我用过那种超大显示器，但关键在于专注。我是一个很容易分心的人。
I can't have like four monitors with all this stuff on it. Now sometimes I am like, okay, like I am switching between windows a lot. But it's just, it's just too, too much, too much for me. So like right now, you just have the teams running an audacity in the background though. That is correct. Yes. Yeah. See like that, if you had a second monitor.
我不能用那种放着所有东西的四显示器。现在有时我会想，好吧，我确实在窗口之间频繁切换。但这对我来说实在太多了，太多了。所以就像现在，你只是在后台运行着Teams和Audacity。没错。是的。你看，如果你有第二台显示器。
You know the thing where I want. I know. I know. But if you had a second monitor. you could make sure that the waves, like the audio waves, if something happens to your mic, you're not going to know. So I do have, the one monitor that I have, like for my desk is a really big monitor, but I never work from the desk anymore. I only work from the laptop. I did finally, I did finally get a new laptop. You know, this last laptop that I got, I got in 2017, right around when I joined Invidia. And I've been waiting three years for Invidia to launch the RTX Spark laptops.
你知道我想要的那种东西。我知道。我知道。但如果你有第二台显示器，你可以确保波形，比如音频波形，如果你的麦克风出了什么问题，你不会知道。所以我确实有一台显示器，我桌面上用的那台是非常大的显示器，但我再也不在桌面上工作了。我只用笔记本电脑工作。我终于，我终于买了一台新笔记本电脑。你知道，我上一台笔记本电脑是2017年买的，就在我加入Nvidia前后。我等了三年，等着Nvidia发布RTX Spark笔记本电脑。
I was going to say, weren't you waiting for a special laptop? Well, I kept saying, I kept saying, you know, I'll just wait, like, oh, it's maybe delayed. It'll come out soon. You know, I'll get an early access one. But then it became clear. So they're coming out this fall, but the thing is that I have to have a laptop that has a 5G Y-WAN chip in it. Because if I'm at a conference or an event or something, I, like, other people would be like, oh, like, I'm having trouble getting on the Wi-Fi or whatnot. I never have that problem.
我正想说，你不是在等一台特别的笔记本电脑吗？嗯，我一直说，我一直说，你知道，我会等的，哦，也许是延期了。它很快就会出来。你知道，我会拿到一台抢先体验版的。但后来很明显了。它们今年秋天会出来，但问题是我必须拥有一台带有5G WAN芯片的笔记本电脑。因为如果我在参加会议或活动什么的，其他人会说，哦，我连接Wi-Fi有困难之类的。我从来没有那个问题。
I have an internal broadband card, like wireless broadband card in my laptop. and I just have international data everywhere, so I just open up the laptop, and it connects, and it works. And that's the most important thing for me. So it became clear to me that probably the first generation of the RTS Spark laptops, it's unlikely to have one that will have the 5G card because it's pretty rare for laptops to have 5G cards. So I broke down, and I bought an HPZ book,
我的笔记本电脑里有内置宽带卡，无线宽带卡。我到处都有国际数据，所以我只要打开笔记本电脑，它就会连接，然后就能用。这对我很重要。所以我很清楚，第一代RTS Spark笔记本电脑不太可能有带5G卡的版本，因为笔记本电脑配备5G卡非常罕见。所以我妥协了，买了一台HP ZBook，
which has, wait for it, an AMD CPU and an AMD GPU. Whoa. This is a work laptop? No, no, no. This is a personal laptop. I've always done bringing my device. Oh, I was going to say, you can't even buy a work laptop with AMD hardware in it. Isn't that right? Also, by the way, you can't tell from the video, but the way my camera's oriented and he's looking at the rightmost monitor, he was like staring at you the entire time. I'm not sure if it's the head of hair. Oh, he's about to cry. Do you want to cry into the mic? All right. Thanks for being on the podcast, buddy. We'll go give you to mom. How's that sound? All right. He says, that sounds good. I'm done with this thing.
它有，等着瞧，AMD CPU和AMD GPU。哇。这是工作笔记本电脑吗？不，不，不。这是个人笔记本电脑。我一直都自带设备。哦，我正想说，你甚至买不到带AMD硬件的工作笔记本电脑。不是吗？另外，顺便说一句，你从视频里看不出来，但我的摄像头方向和我儿子看着最右边显示器的方式，他一直在盯着你看。我不确定是不是因为那头头发。哦，他要哭了。你想对着麦克风哭吗？好吧。谢谢你参加播客，伙计。我们去把你交给妈妈。听起来怎么样？好吧。他说，听起来不错。我不想玩这个了。
I'll be back in a second, then you can continue your HP. One moment. All right, we're back. Babyless. Well, the baby's still in the background, but we were talking about this laptop. I had, we've talked before about the start of my career is kind of an interesting start of my career because I did this drop out of college thing. But there's another aspect in the beginning of my career, which has colored my perspective on programming,
我一会儿就回来，然后你可以继续你的HP。等一下。好了，我们回来了。孩子不在了。嗯，孩子还在背景里，但我们刚才在谈论这台笔记本电脑。我之前谈过我的职业生涯起点，这是一个有趣的起点，因为我做了那种大学辍学的事情。但在我职业生涯的初期还有另一个方面，它影响了我对编程的看法，
which is I started programming and almost immediately was thrown into an H-G, PC environment. So from the start, I was working on concurrent and distributed systems, and specifically in high-performance computing. And, you know, in high-performance computing, you don't do that on your laptop. You connect to somebody else's computer somewhere. And this is colored so much of my experience as a developer. I've largely never used IDs, not necessarily because I think that IDs are bad, but if I'm connecting to insert some supercomputer here. You know, that IDE doesn't run on the supercomputer. Maybe there's some way that I can connect it to the supercomputer today. But let me tell you, in 2011, when I started programming,
那就是我开始编程，几乎立刻就被扔进了HPC（高性能计算）环境。所以从一开始，我就在从事并发和分布式系统的工作，特别是在高性能计算领域。而且，你知道，在高性能计算中，你不能在笔记本电脑上做这些。你连接到某处的别人的计算机。这极大地影响了我作为开发者的经验。我基本上从未使用过IDE，并不是因为我认为IDE不好，而是如果我连接到——在此处插入某台超级计算机——你知道，那个IDE并不会在超级计算机上运行。也许今天有什么方法可以让我把它连接到超级计算机上。但让我告诉你，在2011年，当我开始编程时，
there were not really IDEs that had great support for working remotely on some other machine. And the supercomputers back then and also today, you know, they have pretty bare set of hardware and pretty bare set of software installed. And, you know, it can be a pain. You don't have root access on these machines. It's not your machine. It's somebody else's machine that you're running on. So there's certain stuff that you can't install, et cetera.
并没有真正支持在其他机器上远程工作的优秀IDE。当时的超级计算机，以及今天的超级计算机，你知道，它们安装的硬件和软件非常基础。而且，你知道，这可能很痛苦。你在这些机器上没有root权限。这不是你的机器，而是你在上面运行的别人的机器。所以有些东西你无法安装，等等。
So I, you know, did almost all my development in VIM. And the reason was just VIM is very easy to go and build and install and run yourself. And the build part is actually important, too, because sometimes I would work on some supercomputer that was some funky architecture where there wouldn't be a pre-built binary that I could go and pull. or if there was a pre-built binary package, it wasn't necessarily a package that I could install because back in the day, maybe there'd be a Debian package for something, but again, I wasn't a root user. This was in the age before containers. I had to use these weird HPC package management
所以我，你知道，几乎所有的开发都在VIM中完成。原因仅仅是VIM非常容易构建、安装和运行。构建部分也很重要，因为有时我会在一些架构奇特的超级计算机上工作，那里没有我可以拉取的预构建二进制文件。或者如果有预构建的二进制包，它也不一定是我能安装的包，因为在过去，也许会有Debian包，但同样，我不是root用户。那是在容器时代之前。我必须使用这些奇怪的HPC包管理
systems, which would have a very select set of packages. But anyways, I got used to sort of working in this environment, in particular where I had very few developer tools available to me reliably because on any given day I might be working on some new or different cluster than I was a month ago and where I'm not working on my laptop. And so like, you know, earlier on in my career, yeah, I did have some like beefy laptops and sometimes I would do work developed like locally. But over time, it just increasingly became like my laptop was simply a thin client to some supercomputer somewhere. And there were a lot of benefits to this. One, like if I started doing something like a compilation, or some task, like, and I needed to go somewhere.
系统，它们只有非常有限的包集。但无论如何，我习惯了在这种环境中工作，特别是我几乎没有什么可靠的开发者工具可用，因为在任何一天，我可能都在比一个月前更新或不同的集群上工作，而且我不是在我的笔记本电脑上工作。所以，你知道，在我职业生涯的早期，是的，我确实有一些强劲的笔记本电脑，有时我会进行本地开发。但随着时间的推移，我的笔记本电脑越来越像是一个通往某处超级计算机的瘦客户端。这有很多好处。第一，如果我开始做编译或某些任务，我需要去别的地方，
I could just close my laptop. And, like, you know, the thing would still be happening somewhere on somebody's supercomputer. And I feel like when the agentic era started, this gave me, like, a very different perspective than everyone else. I think, like, a lot of people at the start of the agentic era were running agents, like, locally on their laptops, because that's where a lot of developers do their built. I never did that because, like, that is, like, a very foreign idea to me. Why would I ever want to run something in my laptop?
我可以关上笔记本电脑。而且，你知道，事情仍然会在某人的超级计算机上进行。我觉得当代理时代开始时，这给了我一个与其他人非常不同的视角。我认为，代理时代开始时，很多人都在他们的笔记本电脑上本地运行代理，因为那是很多开发者构建的地方。我从来没有那样做，因为那对我来说是一个非常陌生的想法。我为什么要在我笔记本电脑上运行东西？
And also my laptop's like this weak, pathetic computer. And so I just from the start always ran my agents fully in, you know, some cloud environment in VMs or sandboxes, which is now just a fancy word for VMs. My apologies to the sandbox community. But, I mean, you know it's true. Anyways. So it was never a priority for me how good my laptop was. And I have this like this think pad.
而且我的笔记本电脑是一台弱小、可怜的计算机。所以我从一开始就总是把我的代理完全运行在云环境、虚拟机或沙箱中，现在这只是虚拟机的花哨说法。向沙箱社区道歉。但是，你知道这是真的。总之。所以我的笔记本电脑有多好从来不是我的优先事项。我有这台ThinkPad，
it's the Lenovo Anniversary Edition 25, and it has the classic think pad, keyboard, track pad, and the little nub mouse in the center. And that's like the keyboard that I love that I, you know, used from my like early days. And so I was like, I'm just going to stick with this thing. Even when I bought it, it was not the world's most powerful, like, laptop. But I didn't care because it had the human interface, the like physical interface that I liked. I already, this Z book, the track pad, I'm already like, oh, my gosh. God, I can't stand this thing.
它是Lenovo 25周年纪念版，它有经典的ThinkPad键盘、触控板和中间的小红点鼠标。那是我喜欢的键盘，我从早期就开始用了。所以我当时想，我就坚持用这个东西。即使在我买它的时候，它也不是世界上最强大的笔记本电脑。但我不在乎，因为它有我喜欢的人机界面，那种物理界面。我已经，这台ZBook，触控板，我已经，哦，天哪。天哪，我受不了这个东西。
Like, there's no button to right-click. I have to just click on the bottom right of the thing. Like, I want a physical button. But anyway. So the thing that ultimately, like, killed it from me. Well, this laptop's been on its last. One, the microphone's kind of been dying. And then two, I use whisperflow to do text to speech.
就像，没有右键按钮。我必须点击那个东西的右下角。就像，我想要一个物理按钮。但不管怎样。所以最终让我放弃它的原因。嗯，这台笔记本电脑已经快不行了。第一，麦克风有点坏了。然后第二，我用Whisperflow进行语音转文字。
But whisper flow seems to be having some issue with the microphone. So if I have whisper flow running, sometimes, like, the microphone driver just completely crashes or like something happens where like I'll be in the middle of a of a call like this call and then suddenly my microphone will just completely go out. And then I did start running some agent tasks locally, like in particular like things like computer use where I wanted to have access to my browser or something where like I needed it to like set up something or debug a problem on my laptop. I would run it. I would run an agent for that. And what I quickly ran into was like this thing just is not powerful enough to even run the Codex desktop app.
但Whisperflow似乎在麦克风上有一些问题。所以如果我运行Whisperflow，有时，麦克风驱动程序就会完全崩溃，或者发生一些事情，比如我正在通话中——就像这次通话——然后突然我的麦克风就完全没声音了。然后我开始在本地运行一些代理任务，特别是像计算机使用这类任务，我需要访问我的浏览器或者其他东西，我需要它来设置某些东西或调试我笔记本电脑上的问题。我会运行它。我会为此运行一个代理。我很快遇到的问题是，这台机器甚至不足以运行Codex桌面应用程序。
Because this is like a two-core laptop. I did upgrade it some number of years ago to 64 gigs of memory, which is a thing you used to be able to do on laptops. You used to be able to buy new memory and put it into the laptops because everything was modular, but now they're not. Now it's all, I mean, the Z-book actually that I got actually did have configurable memory, but not all of them do. Anyways, that's my old man tirade about my old laptop.
因为这是一台双核笔记本电脑。我确实在几年前把它升级到了64GB内存，这是你以前可以在笔记本电脑上做的事情。你以前可以买新内存并把它装进笔记本电脑，因为一切都是模块化的，但现在不是了。现在全是，我是说，我买的那台ZBook确实有可配置的内存，但并不是所有的都有。总之，这就是我关于旧笔记本电脑的老年人抱怨。
The old laptop also, like, in addition to like the microphone dying, and now like Windows is like not really stable on it anymore. And it's a Windows 10 laptop because it does not meet the hardware requirements to upgrade to Windows 11. There's an issue. And like Windows Explorer crashes a lot and other apps crash a lot and Chrome freezes up a lot. And it is now like more recently, it has started to develop physical ailments. Like there are parts of it that are like literally falling off. Like there's a corner that's chipped now. There's parts where like the plastic is wearing through.
旧笔记本电脑除了麦克风坏了之外，现在Windows在上面也不太稳定了。这是一台Windows 10笔记本电脑，因为它不符合升级到Windows 11的硬件要求。这是一个问题。而且Windows资源管理器经常崩溃，其他应用程序也经常崩溃，Chrome经常卡死。最近它开始出现物理故障。比如有些部分真的在掉落。比如有一个角现在碎了。有些地方塑料磨损了。
This thing has seen a lot and it is time for it to be retired. So soon the new laptop will be fully onboarded. Ah, and I shall start over. A fantastic opportunity to get rid of Windows and start fresh, not just from any Linux distribution, which, oh boy, oh boy, are we going to lose some listeners here, folks? You know, because I messaged you about this leading up to setting up this recording. And I took a break last week because I was in the second week of my Pat leave. And I could have set up a recording, but honestly, I was pretty tired.
这东西经历了很多，是时候让它退休了。所以很快新笔记本电脑就会完全投入使用。啊，我将重新开始。这是一个绝佳的机会，可以摆脱Windows，重新开始，不仅仅是任何Linux发行版，哦，天哪，天哪，我们要失去一些听众了，伙计们？你知道，因为我在设置这次录音之前给你发了消息。我上周休息了一下，因为我在休陪产假的第二周。我本可以安排录音，但老实说，我太累了。
And I was like, you know what? I deserve a break. We're just going to take a week off. I'm going to record one of my seven to ten minute podcasts and just refer people to other podcasts. And I went ahead and referred people to a bunch of podcasts. One of them, did you listen to the Jensen interview with Ezra Klein or did that cross your radar? I've seen that. I've seen people complaining about that on Twitter.
我当时想，你知道吗？我应该休息一下。我们休息一周。我要录制一个七到十分钟的播客，然后把大家推荐给其他播客。我继续把大家推荐给了一堆播客。其中一个，你听了Jensen和Ezra Klein的采访吗，还是那没进入你的视野？我见过。我看到人们在Twitter上抱怨那个。
Yeah, he upset a lot of people. A lot of people are upset that he said long divisions no longer required. And maybe we should do a whole episode dedicated to reviewing our thought. The point that I'm trying to get to here has nothing to do with Jensen. It was that I mentioned DHH, who is a, I don't even know his full name, David, 2Hs. And he's a Ruby guy. And he was on Lex Friedman and he had a five-hour podcast. And then more recently, I didn't mention this last week.
是的，他让很多人不高兴。很多人对他说不再需要长除法感到不满。也许我们应该专门做一集来回顾我们的想法。我这里想表达的观点与Jensen无关。我提到的是DHH，他是一个，我甚至不知道他的全名，David，2个H。他是个Ruby开发者。他上了Lex Friedman的节目，做了一个五小时的播客。然后最近，我上周没提到这个。
He gave a keynote at Rails World, which apparently, there's a whole controversy behind that as well because he was not invited one year to speak at RailsConf and then that and then he like boycotted that set up Rails World as like a competing conference and then RailsConf ended up like folding because it couldn't financially survive anyways apparently there's a whole lot of drama behind this guy you know what we need to put that to the side and I know we've lost listeners before because we mentioned Elon and then people get upset because you listen folks I don't endorse any of his political of beliefs we We accept all people here.
他在Rails World上发表了主题演讲，显然，这背后也有很多争议，因为他有一年没被邀请在RailsConf上发言，然后他抵制了那个会议，设立了Rails World作为竞争会议，然后RailsConf最终倒闭了，因为它在经济上无法生存。总之，显然这个家伙背后有很多戏剧性事件。你知道吗，我们需要把这些放在一边，我知道我们之前因为提到Elon而失去过听众，然后人们会不高兴，因为听着，伙计们，我不支持他的任何政治信仰。我们这里接受所有人。
We are equal opportunity, equal everything. We love everybody. You know, let's all just get along. That being said, let's set aside this guy's political things. What he's doing right now, it's fantastic. Apparently there's this stop-omachi.com site, and you shouldn't do it. But listen, folks, it's like when I used to eat at Chick-fil-A. You know, Chick-fil-A had some views I didn't agree with.
我们是机会均等，一切平等。我们爱每一个人。你知道，让我们相处融洽吧。话虽如此，让我们把这个家伙的政治观点放在一边。他现在做的事情，太棒了。显然有一个stop-omachi.com网站，你不应该那样做。但听着，伙计们，这就像我以前在Chick-fil-A吃饭一样。你知道，Chick-fil-A有一些我不认同的观点。
But they also had the best fried chicken sandwich out there, and it wasn't close. You're going to get canceled, Connor. You're going to be canceled. You're going to end up in, like, tomorrow you're going to be going to be going to be like, oh, I can't. None of this is usable. It is usable. It is usable. Is it?
但他们也有那里最好的炸鸡三明治，而且差距很大。你会因为这个被取消的，Connor。你会因为这个被取消的。你最终会，就像，明天你就会，就会，就会说，哦，我不能。这些都不能用。它是可用的。它是可用的。是吗？
I mean, I'm not, okay, here's my point. I'm happy to switch to another fried chicken sandwich, which I did. In Toronto, there's a boutique institution called Tokyo Fried Chicken. I always get my, I live in a different place now, so I'm not close to that. But when I was downtown, I would always order there. I never went to Chick-fil-A. But at the time, there was a time when I lived in the States, it was the best fried chicken sandwich I knew. about and I would go there knowing that I didn't agree with the beliefs of the management,
我是说，我不是，好吧，这是我的观点。我很乐意换成另一个炸鸡三明治，我也确实这么做了。在多伦多，有一家精品店叫Tokyo Fried Chicken。我总是买我的，我现在住在不同的地方，所以我离那儿不近。但当我在市中心时，我总是去那里点餐。我从来不去Chick-fil-A。但在当时，我住在美国的时候，那是我知道的最好的炸鸡三明治，我会去那里，尽管我知道我不认同管理层的信仰，
but it was still the best fried chicken sandwich. I'm not going to not eat the best fried chicken sandwich if the next step down is so much worse. And that's what Omachi is, folks. It's an agentic AI first operating system. I'm running it right now. It's technically Arch. Who cares though? And it has like codex and quad code, everything built into it. You can change anything about the computer. You don't like something? You just ask, just ask it to be changed. I have a completely configured, custom configured computer now. that different from what I have, which is I just install Windows 11 and then the Codex desktop app and then to set up anything in the computer, I just whisper flow into Codex and tell it to do the
但它仍然是最好的炸鸡三明治。如果下一个选择差得多，我不会不吃最好的炸鸡三明治。这就是Omachi，伙计们。这是一个以代理AI为先的操作系统。我现在正在运行它。它技术上是Arch。但谁在乎呢？它内置了Codex和Quad Code，一切。你可以改变计算机的任何东西。你不喜欢什么？你只要问，只要让它改变就行了。我现在有一台完全配置好、自定义配置的计算机。这和我以前的不同，以前我只是安装Windows 11，然后安装Codex桌面应用程序，然后要设置计算机里的任何东西，我只是对着Codex使用Whisperflow，告诉它做
thing that I want. Does that work as seamlessly and as integrated when it's like built from scratch? Can you go and like completely destroy like the file explorer and replace it with like some other thing? Probably not, but I don't feel like I need to. Listen, I'll tell you that. I mean, I'm not saying you want to replace the file explorer but i'm just saying like everything one of my primary is possible now one of my primary functions like the things that i use most one is like a terminal to some other computer i can do that anywhere then like powerpoint and excel and google chrome you can do google chrome anywhere but but powerpoint and excel you're going to have the best experience on windows and one of the things with powerpoint is i often need to plug my laptop into
我想要的事情。当它是从零开始构建时，它能像那样无缝集成吗？你能去彻底摧毁文件资源管理器并用其他东西替换它吗？可能不行，但我觉得我不需要。听着，我会告诉你。我是说，我不是说你想替换文件资源管理器，但我只是说，我最主要的功能之一现在是可能的，我最常用的功能之一，一个是通往另一台计算机的终端，我可以在任何地方做那个，然后是PowerPoint、Excel和Google Chrome，你可以在任何地方使用Google Chrome，但是PowerPoint和Excel，你在Windows上会有最好的体验，而且PowerPoint的问题之一是我经常需要把我的笔记本电脑插到
somebody's projector somewhere to project something. And I've never seen people struggle as much to do that with Windows as they have with things that are not Windows. And I mean, you know... You got a problem in the future? You drop down to Codex and say, fix my connection issue. That's exactly what I did with my media laptop,
某处的投影仪上进行投影。我从来没见过人们在使用非Windows系统时像使用Windows那样在做这件事上挣扎。我是说，你知道……未来你遇到问题了？你进入Codex说，修复我的连接问题。这正是我在我的媒体笔记本电脑上做的，
except I wasn't on Omachi at that point. I'm still on Ubuntu downstairs. But like, for whatever... Because I'm running Ubuntu on like a MacBook Pro from 2012. So it's got a bunch of like kernel issues and whatnot. and connecting to the PC from like the sources on the TV was always so finicky. And then I was like, wait a second. I have codex here.
除了那时我还没用Omachi。我楼下还在用Ubuntu。但不管……因为我在2012年的MacBook Pro上运行Ubuntu。所以它有很多内核问题之类的。而且从电视上的源连接到PC总是很麻烦。然后我就想，等一下。我这里有Codex。
And so I said codex, like figure out what's wrong. I just want when I, when I click PC, I always want it. And it found a bunch of issues. And so now whenever I restart the computer, my BashRC file runs like a little script that does some like HDMI audio like codec resetting. And it works perfectly now. So like if you ever add a, here's a challenge. If you're ever on Linux in the future trying to connect to some.
所以我说Codex，找出问题所在。我只是想当我点击PC时，我总是想要它。它发现了一堆问题。所以现在每当我重启计算机时，我的BashRC文件就会运行一个小脚本，做一些HDMI音频编解码器重置。现在它工作得非常完美。所以如果你将来在Linux上尝试连接到某个
projector, you drop down into Codex, boom. Codex solves that. In fact, when I installed the Machi for the first time on my workstation, I've got like two different GPUs, one on the motherboard, which is like a really old Pascal P620 GPU, and then I've got a Quadro RTX, which is still pretty old. It's like a TURRTX, it got confused somehow, tried to hook up to the Quadro RTX 8,000, and then like ended up just like the GUI wouldn't open. So you're in TTILAND, which is like, honestly, when you're dealing with Invidia
投影仪，你进入Codex，砰。Codex解决了这个问题。事实上，当我第一次在工作站上安装Omachi时，我有两块不同的GPU，一块在主板上，是那种非常老旧的Pascal P620 GPU，然后我还有一块Quadro RTX，也相当老了。它就像是一块TURRTX，它不知怎么搞混了，试图连接到Quadro RTX 8000，然后结果就是图形界面打不开了。所以你就进入了TTY模式，老实说，当你处理Nvidia
drivers, if you've been doing this for the last decade, it's a normal thing, but guess what? Omachi has codex built in from scratch. You drop down into codex. It took me like a couple minutes to realize I could do that. And then it's got three different sign-in methods. Even though I'm in like TTILand, I don't need a browser. You can sign in from another device. I sign it from the other device.
驱动程序时，如果你过去十年一直都在做这个，这是很正常的事情，但你猜怎么着？Omachi内置了从零开始构建的Codex。你进入Codex。我花了大概几分钟才意识到我可以这样做。而且它有三种不同的登录方式。即使我处于TTY模式，我也不需要浏览器。你可以从另一台设备登录。我从另一台设备登录。
And then boom, I got codex. I said codex. I've got some driver issues solved it for. I was thinking about trying, you know, I used to run only Linux. I mean, I famously, you know, back in the day was running Linux on my map. Not that famous. Well, I was the first person to compile the Linux current. with LVM, just saying.
然后砰，我就有了Codex。我说Codex。我解决了一些驱动程序问题。我当时在想尝试，你知道，我以前只运行Linux。我是说，我很有名，你知道，在过去，我在我的Mac上运行Linux。不是那么有名。好吧，我是第一个用LVM编译Linux内核的人，只是说说而已。
My first claim to frame, at some point it just got to be like, you know, too much work. And I just sort of, I did dual boots for a while, and then I just found myself spending on my time in the Windows machine. I have thought, I did think recently about whether I can go to Linux. And one of my questions there was like, what's the experience of running PowerPoint and wine? And it's apparently not, not great. Bro, and also, too, PowerPoint's dead.
我第一个成名作，在某个时候它变得，你知道，工作量太大了。我只是，我双启动了一段时间，然后我发现我大部分时间都花在Windows机器上。我曾想过，我最近确实想过我是否可以转向Linux。我其中的一个问题是，在Wine上运行PowerPoint的体验如何？显然不是，不是很好。兄弟，而且，PowerPoint已经死了。
Powerpoint's dead. What are you doing? You get codex to write all your slide decks. My first presentation that I gave post the big jump, which was like tail end of November in 2025, happened to be in December. I was speaking at conference down in Australia. And I didn't even realize. Like, nobody was talking about how good the jump was.
PowerPoint已经死了。你在做什么？你让Codex写你所有的幻灯片。我在大跳跃之后做的第一个演示，大约是在2025年11月底，恰好是在12月。我在澳大利亚的一个会议上发言。我甚至没意识到。就像，没人谈论那个跳跃有多好。
And I was just like, I started off with the title slide, with the Matrix Rain. And then I was like, oh, I'll add an about me. And then I was like, wait a sec. This is so good. Like, can't I keep going? You don't need PowerPoint. I will give you a piece of career advice that your bot manager gave me, which is, you know, I was, back in the day, I used to use my own templates that was not the Nvidia PowerPoint
我当时只是，我从标题幻灯片开始，带有矩阵雨。然后我当时想，哦，我会加一个关于我。然后我当时想，等一下。这太好了。就像，我不能继续吗？你不需要PowerPoint。我会给你一个你的机器人经理给我的职业建议，那就是，你知道，我，在过去，我习惯使用我自己的模板，那不是Nvidia PowerPoint
template. I still kind of do, but back in the day, he asked me, hey, can you use the Nvidia PowerPoint template? Because that makes it easier for other people to incorporate your stuff into their slides. And the sort of broader lesson there is that sometimes you shouldn't necessarily use the best tool for yourself personally. Sometimes you have to think about what is the ecosystem around you, the ecosystem of the organization that you are in. And like at NVIDIA, the one, the majority of our existing like content is PowerPoint documents, Google documents, you know, Microsoft Word, et cetera. That's the majority of existing content. And so if I need to, like, a lot of times that I'm making a slide deck or a presentation or
模板。我仍然有点这样做，但在过去，他问我，嘿，你能使用Nvidia PowerPoint模板吗？因为这让其他人更容易将你的东西合并到他们的幻灯片中。这里更广泛的教训是，有时你不一定非要为自己个人使用最好的工具。有时你必须考虑你周围的生态系统，你所处的组织的生态系统。就像在NVIDIA，我们现有的绝大多数内容是PowerPoint文档、Google文档，你知道，Microsoft Word等等。那是现有内容的大部分。所以如果我需要，就像，很多时候我在制作幻灯片或演示文稿或
something, 80% of it is stuff that I've already have from other decks that I'm just piecing together. And if I had to go and move to a completely new framework, that would be harder to do. But then also, I have to collaborate with other people, and I got to share things with other people. And those other people need to be able to use them. And we all have to agree upon a common format, a common, like, you know, unit of exchange. And at Nvidia, that is PowerPoint. I mean, some people use, like, Google slides. But that's actually fairly rare. And there's all sorts of issues when people use Google slides. So, yeah, actually, when you, when you mentioned this, I was thinking at one point I did do something in Google slides. And my manager was like, well, can you turn this into PowerPoint?
什么的时候，80%的内容是我已经从其他幻灯片中拥有的，我只是把它们拼凑在一起。如果我必须去转向一个全新的框架，那会更难做到。但同时，我必须与其他人合作，我必须与其他人分享东西。而那些人需要能够使用它们。我们都必须同意一个共同的格式，一个共同的，你知道，交换单位。而在Nvidia，那就是PowerPoint。我是说，有些人使用，比如，Google Slides。但这实际上相当罕见。而且当人们使用Google Slides时，会有各种各样的问题。所以，是的，实际上，当你提到这个时，我当时在想，有一次我确实在Google Slides里做了一些东西。我的经理说，嗯，你能把它变成PowerPoint吗？
Like, I need to copy it into my slide deck. And I was like, oh, yeah, fair point. So you are not without a solid point. I still don't think PowerPoints. And also, too, you give more, you do more presentations and like training and stuff. Like probably by a fact at this point, like, ever since I switched to research, factor of five, maybe an order of magnitude, factor of 10. So that's probably more, like, honestly, I've spoken at one conference this year. And then the one before that was the one back in December. So my conferencing has taken a precipitous decline, as opposed to you. You've been traveling the world all year.
就像，我需要把它复制到我的幻灯片里。然后我说，哦，是的，有道理。所以你不是没有道理。我仍然不认为PowerPoint是。而且，你做更多的演示和培训之类的。就像可能在这一点上，自从我转向研究以来，因素是五倍，也许是一个数量级，十倍。所以这可能更多，老实说，我今年在一个会议上发言。然后在那之前的一个是12月的那次。所以我的会议参加率急剧下降，和你相反。你整年都在环游世界。
But anyways, give a thought. Give it a shot, buddy. Watch the DHS World. I was thinking about it with the new laptop. I was thinking about trying Linux, going back to Linux. And if it's a new laptop, apparently, like for me, installing it on my workstation, took, I think, two minutes. And for my work laptop, it took three and a half.
但不管怎样，想一想。试一试，伙计。看看DHS World。我当时在想新笔记本电脑的事。我当时在想尝试Linux，回到Linux。如果这是一台新笔记本电脑，显然，对我来说，在我的工作站上安装它，我想，花了大约两分钟。对于我的工作笔记本电脑，花了三分钟半。
but they're claiming that like for speedy machines it's less than a minute to install like you flash the USB and it installs in less than a minute. So you mean it's not even going to cost you that much time, you know? And it's beautiful. It's beautiful. I'm not sure if you've ever used a tiling window system. It is the reality is that a good chunk of what I do on Windows is Windows would be a lot less usable for me if not for WSL, especially these days. So it's sort of like it's a question of whether I run Windows where I'm doing a lot of stuff in WSL or whether I well in Linux, where I'm doing a lot of stuff in a Windows VM.
但他们声称对于快速机器来说安装时间不到一分钟，就像你刷入USB，它在一分钟内就安装好了。所以你的意思是它甚至不会花费你那么多时间，你知道吗？而且它很漂亮。它很漂亮。我不确定你是否用过平铺窗口系统。现实是，我在Windows上做的大部分工作，如果没有WSL，Windows对我来说会少用很多，特别是在这些日子里。所以这就像是一个问题，是我运行Windows，我在WSL里做很多事情，还是我，嗯，在Linux里，我在Windows虚拟机里做很多事情。
And that's the thing is if you're in WSL or WSL2, you know, I set my brother-in-law, he had Super GROC and he saw some of the stuff I was doing. And I was like, let me just, because I was, it would have been easier for me to just, like, teach a man to fish. So I basically took his laptop, set up WSL2, set up Super GROC. And, like, I ran into some issues because you do have access to the whole file system from there, but you kind of have to, like, it's like a, what do you call it, like a crab trap.
这就是问题所在，如果你在WSL或WSL2里，你知道，我设置了我姐夫的，他有Super GROC，他看到了我正在做的一些事情。我当时想，让我只是，因为我当时，对我来说，授人以渔会更容易。所以我基本上拿了他的笔记本电脑，设置了WSL2，设置了Super GROC。而且，我遇到了一些问题，因为你确实可以从那里访问整个文件系统，但你有点必须，就像，它就像一个，你叫它什么，就像一个蟹笼。
You got to go like outside and then around to get to the rest of the ocean. The point being that it is possible, but a couple times when I was asking it to like make changes to its kind of environment, it would reset every single time. He like went in and out of GRO and I was like, yeah, this is just an issue you're going to have to live with with WSL2. Whereas if you're on native Linux, regardless of your distro, you're never going to have to have that issue, right? Yeah.
你必须去外面，然后绕一圈才能到达海洋的其余部分。重点是它是可能的，但有几次当我要求它对它的环境进行更改时，它每次都会重置。他进出GRO，我当时想，是的，这是你使用WSL2必须忍受的问题。而如果你在原生Linux上，无论你的发行版是什么，你永远不会遇到那个问题，对吧？是的。
Well, maybe the title of this episode will be, Will Bryce switch to Linux? The biggest problem is what do I do about all my. existing PowerPoint decks that I don't really have a realistic way to like interact with from Linux other than maybe a VM but then that's a pain if I have to like you know screen share yeah it's a huge problem because the PowerPoint's web powerpoint doesn't work very well people in the comments yeah I know about Microsoft 365 the web app is not the same experience as it's not it's not as good and things and it's not the same rendering engines and things do not render the same. One of the beautiful things, though, it does seem that for whatever reason on
嗯，也许这一集的标题会是，Bryce会转向Linux吗？最大的问题是我该怎么处理我现有的所有PowerPoint幻灯片，除了虚拟机之外，我没有现实的方法可以从Linux与它们交互，但如果我必须，你知道，屏幕共享，那很痛苦。是的，这是一个巨大的问题，因为PowerPoint网页版PowerPoint工作得不是很好，评论区的人们，是的，我知道Microsoft 365，网页应用和它不是一样的体验，它不是，它没那么好，而且事情不是一样的渲染引擎，东西渲染得不一样。不过，其中一件美妙的事情是，无论出于什么原因，在
Omachi, it works slightly better. There was one issue that I always had with the online Microsoft PowerPoint color picker. It like couldn't get the color picker of the screen correct. It was always off. And so if anyone pays attention real close attention to the array cast thumbnails pre-episode 130 on YouTube, you'll see that there's like two slightly different shades of blue because the color picker doesn't work, but on Omachi, works seamlessly, perfectly. I don't know why Arch is better than Ubuntu, I think it was on 2404,
Omachi上，它工作得稍微好一点。我一直有一个关于在线Microsoft PowerPoint颜色选择器的问题。它无法正确获取屏幕的颜色选择器。它总是偏离。所以如果有人非常仔细地关注YouTube上第130集之前的Array Cast缩略图，你会看到有两种略有不同的蓝色，因为颜色选择器不起作用，但在Omachi上，工作得无缝、完美。我不知道为什么Arch比Ubuntu好，我想它是在2404上，
whatever the latest LPS was. I'm a Debbie in person. It would be, it's, yeah, I'm a Debian person. I don't know that I want to go learn Arch. Well, that's the thing. You don't even need to learn Arch. You just ask codex everything, you know? I'm an old man, Connor.
无论最新的LPS是什么。我是Debian用户。它会是，是的，我是Debian用户。我不知道我是否想去学习Arch。嗯，这就是重点。你甚至不需要学习Arch。你只要问Codex一切，你知道？我是个老头子，Connor。
I'm an old man. All right, should we bundle, because I had a couple topics I wanted to talk about. Should we bundle those in to this episode because we're at the 27 minute mark? we could rapid fire them and then all right we're keeping it well people don't know what we cut but we cut that part yeah or we 10x and made me sound like a chipmunk anyways so i mentioned the dh8 stuff i mentioned the agentic OS and oh we'll leave my AI apps for later i'll just i'll just show
我是个老头子。好了，我们应该捆绑吗，因为我有几个想谈的话题。我们应该把它们捆绑到这一集里吗，因为我们已经到了27分钟了？我们可以快速过一遍，然后好了，我们保持它，嗯，人们不知道我们剪掉了什么，但我们剪掉了那部分，是的，或者我们10倍速播放，让我听起来像个花栗鼠。总之，我提到了DH8的东西，我提到了代理操作系统，哦，我们会把我的AI应用留到以后，我只是，我只是会展示
you bryce that thanks to being inspired by dhhhh you can now see basically the bottom row of my phone they're all the same icon we've got pod god stock god fam god baby god home god and healy chubb. We are replacing all of these irritating ad-ridden apps with, and let's go, look at this, look at this, buddy. This is my stock app, which is, it's fine. What's that? Conner now has investments?
给你，Bryce，多亏了受到DHHHH的启发，你现在基本上可以看到我手机的底行。它们都是同一个图标。我们有Pod God、Stock God、Fam God、Baby God、Home God和Healy Chubb。我们正在用这些东西替换所有那些令人恼火的、充满广告的应用程序，来吧，看看这个，看看这个，伙计。这是我的股票应用程序，它是，它很好。那是什么？Conner现在有投资了？
I remember pre-dad Conner where he's like, it's all just funny money, it's all just going to be in video. I'm just going to get rid of. It is all still in video. I don't have investments. I just like looking at the prices of other companies. I still only own one stock folks. Diversification as, was it Mark Twain,
我记得当爸爸之前的Conner，他说，这全是好玩的钱，全都会投进Nvidia。我只是要摆脱它。它仍然全都在Nvidia。我没有投资。我只是喜欢看其他公司的价格。我仍然只拥有一只股票，伙计们。多元化，是Mark Twain说的吗，
or some famous person said, maybe Warren Buffett, It's for people that don't know what they're doing. And let me tell you, folks, I know what I'm doing. But you can see on this second page, it's a sexy version of the top market cap companies. It's got little red letters as the prices change. It's just absolutely beautiful, folks. Anyways, we're slowly, you can do everything now. You got some irritating app?
或者某个名人说的，也许是Warren Buffett，这是给那些不知道自己在做什么的人准备的。让我告诉你，伙计们，我知道我在做什么。但你可以在第二页看到，它是顶级市值公司的性感版本。当价格变化时，它有红色的小字母。它绝对漂亮，伙计们。总之，我们正在慢慢地，你现在可以做任何事情。你有一些令人恼火的应用程序？
Done. It's gone. And let me tell you, I'll tell you about Home God. It's my smart home app. It's amazing. Anyways, we're taking over. New operating system. One thing that's very interesting is you are.
完成了。它没了。让我告诉你，我会告诉你关于Home God的事。这是我的智能家居应用程序。它太棒了。总之，我们正在接管。新操作系统。有一件事非常有趣，那就是你。
Like, me on the consumer and, like, personal side, I am much more conservative with what I will use AI to do. Whereas on the work side, I am, like, very, like, over leveraged. Maybe, I mean, we're probably at a similar scale there. But, like, on the home side, I'm a lot more conservative. Like, I'm not, I don't feel the need. There's not that many things where I have the need to use at home. I do use it now for some of my travel planning and, like, tracking things like that. I feel like you are far more on that side of it.
就像，在消费者和个人方面，我在使用AI做的事情上要保守得多。而在工作方面，我，就像，非常，就像，过度杠杆化。也许，我是说，我们可能在那个规模上相似。但是，在家庭方面，我保守得多。就像，我不是，我不觉得有必要。没有那么多事情是我在家里有必要使用的。我现在确实用它来做一些旅行计划和，就像，跟踪之类的事情。我觉得你在那方面要多得多。
I can't think of like a thing where I'd be like, oh, I want like my own version of this app. Like this existing app like isn't it good enough for me? I can't, I don't have a version of that. You think of that, but that's, I'm trying to figure out the exact. I'm sure that there are things. I just haven't. It's just that like I don't feel like, I don't feel like I have time.
我想不出有什么事情我会说，哦，我想要我自己的这个应用程序版本。就像这个现有的应用程序对我来说不够好吗？我不能，我没有那个版本。你想到那个，但那是，我正在试图弄清楚确切的。我相信有这样的事情。我只是还没有。只是像我没有时间。
You know, it's actually actually an interesting like aspect of my work life balance where I've never understood people who have time for like side coding projects. You're not coding anymore. You're just directing. No, no, I know. I get that. But like, like even in the era before, I never, like, you did more like, you know, fun projects on the side.
你知道，这实际上是我工作与生活平衡中一个有趣的方面，我从来不理解那些有时间做副业编码项目的人。你不再编码了。你只是在指导。不，不，我知道。我明白。但就像，即使在那个时代之前，我从来没有，就像，你做了更多，你知道，有趣的副业项目。
You've always done more like stuff on the side that's like fun or exciting. Me, almost all of my coding has almost all of my like software engineering work has been like exclusively on like my primary work mission or like slightly adjacent like work. missions and that I always feel like I have no time for anything other than like the three or four major work things there on my plate and like I guess can't imagine how people would have the time like I can't I can't envision how you have the time even with AI to build something like podcast well I've been admittedly I mentioned in last week's episode I've started the release process but like you have to get a certain kind of number and then Google's got to review it I thought it was like you could
你总是做一些副业，比如那些有趣或令人兴奋的事情。而我，几乎所有的编程工作，几乎所有的软件工程工作，都完全专注于我的主要工作任务，或者稍微相关的工作任务。我总觉得除了手头那三四件主要工作外，我没有时间做任何其他事情。我猜我无法想象人们怎么会有时间，即使有了人工智能，去构建像播客这样的东西。好吧，我承认，我在上周的节目中提到过，我已经开始了发布流程，但你必须达到一定的数量，然后谷歌还得审核它。我原以为就像你可以
just throw an app. Like, I thought Flappy Bird, I just assume it went on the play store like a day after it was finished. It takes weeks. And so I don't think it's going to be out until October. But I've been working on PodGod since February, like since late January. And I think I've really let perfection be the enemy of good or like even great because like my podcast player is better than every other podcast player out there. But it still has bugs here and there. And I feel like because it's completely like developed agentically, like I'm going to get so much criticism for like, oh, you see, it doesn't work. And it's like, well, no, all the other ones don't fricking work too or, like, don't have
直接发布一个应用程序。就像《Flappy Bird》，我以为它在完成后的第二天就上了应用商店。但这需要几周时间。所以我认为它要到十月才能发布。但我从二月，也就是一月下旬开始就一直在做 PodGod。我想我真的让完美成了优秀的敌人，甚至成了卓越的敌人，因为我的播客播放器比市面上所有的播客播放器都要好。但它仍然有一些小毛病。我觉得因为它是完全通过智能体开发的，所以我肯定会受到很多批评，比如‘你看，它根本不能用’。而我想说，不，其他所有的软件也他妈的不能用，或者说，没有
the features that I want. Anyway, so it has taken months, but like now, putting up a simple stock god, you know, track a few things and, like, you know, that takes like 20 minutes, you know, it doesn't take that much time. And also, it takes 20 minutes for the AI. It takes, like, 30 seconds for me to draft the prompt and then another four minutes of like, no, no, no, I want square logos. I want center.
我想要的功能。总之，这花了好几个月，但现在，发布一个简单的股票应用，你知道，追踪一些东西，那只需要20分钟，你知道，不需要花太多时间。而且，人工智能只需要20分钟。我写提示词只需要30秒，然后再加上四分钟的调整，比如‘不，不，不，我想要方形的图标。我想要居中。’
I want spacing. Anyway, so I, no, no, it's not about time. It's that if I, if I would, if I had that. time, I would have spent that time on a new work project, not on something for me. Oh, yeah, maybe fair enough. But that's like, that comes into like a intrinsic, extrinsic, like, where do you get your purpose in life? That's what I'm getting at.
‘我想要间距。’总之，我，不，不，这不是时间的问题。而是如果我，如果我有那个时间，我会把时间花在一个新的工作项目上，而不是花在自己的事情上。哦，是的，也许有道理。但这涉及到内在和外在的动机，比如，你的人生目标从哪里来？这就是我想说的。
It's like, for me, like, I never used to think of myself as a workaholic. But I think that is one of the signs that I am a workaholic. Yeah, I'm like a work slash side projectaholic. Yeah. I'm not, like, I have never, like, maybe early on in my. career, I had a few hobby projects, like the Linux kernel thing. But very quickly, it became like, like, I've never really had, like, hobbyist programming projects since then. It's all just been whatever my main focus is. And that if I had spare cycles, maybe I would take on a new, like,
就像，对我来说，我从来没把自己看作是一个工作狂。但我认为这是我是工作狂的迹象之一。是的，我是一个工作加副业狂。是的。我从来没有，也许在职业生涯早期，我有过几个业余项目，比如 Linux 内核那个。但很快，它就变成了，我从那以后就再也没有过业余编程项目了。所有的精力都集中在我的主要工作上。如果我有空闲时间，也许我会承担一个新的，比如
work project. Yeah. I don't know what this is about. Yeah, that's just like what, whatever charges your wheel or whatever. Anyway, the last, the last two things I was going to mention, one of them is in our updated ADSP thepodcast.com website. We've got new stats that you can go and check out. But one of the things, I sent you the important takeaway was by year percentage of episodes that have guests. And since 20, we peaked at 2023 with 62%, 2024 was 42%, 2025 was 37.
工作项目。是的。我不知道这说明了什么。是的，这只是什么让你充满动力之类的。总之，最后两件事我想提一下，其中之一是我们更新了 ADSPthepodcast.com 网站。我们有了新的统计数据，你可以去看看。但我发给你的重要结论是按年份统计的带有嘉宾的剧集百分比。自2020年以来，我们在2023年达到顶峰，占比62%，2024年是42%，2025年是37%。
And in 2026, folks, we're down to 23%. Really? And so this episode and probably the next episode that we're going to release a little bit later will be hopefully for Bryce and the last two, just us, well maybe do one other. But I want to get that. I want to see if we can get above 37%.
而在2026年，各位，我们下降到了23%。真的吗？所以这一集，以及我们稍后可能会发布的下一集，希望对 Bryce 来说是最后两集只有我们两个人的节目，也许我们会再做一集。但我想要那个。我想看看我们能否超过37%。
Because admittedly, we've gotten feedback at our annual reviews where people like the interviews. And I don't know why I guess we've just been having too much fun chatting about AI. And we know that we're both excited about AI. And so it's always a risk. To be fair, we've also both had a lot going on. And it like requires more thinking ahead of time in scheduling and planning instead of us just like, oh, we got to record. Let's hop on at 4 p.m. on a Thursday. But I totally, I am all for more guests.
因为不可否认，我们在年度评估中收到了反馈，人们喜欢访谈节目。我不知道为什么，我猜我们只是太沉迷于聊人工智能了。我们都知道我们俩都对人工智能很兴奋。所以这总是一个风险。公平地说，我们俩最近都很忙。这需要更多的提前思考、安排和规划，而不是像我们现在这样，‘哦，我们得录音了。让我们周四下午4点上线吧。’但我完全支持邀请更多的嘉宾。
Yes. And, yeah, I mean, I love doing guest episodes. I think the audience loves doing guest episodes. I always learn something in guest episodes. I feel like, I guess I always learn something talking to Connor anyways. But like I learn, I both learned something and like become closer with some new friend. So I love it. So yeah, we were even going to have a guest today, but they have not replied.
是的。而且，我的意思是，我喜欢做有嘉宾的节目。我认为听众也喜欢有嘉宾的节目。我在有嘉宾的节目中总能学到东西。我觉得，我猜我跟 Connor 聊天时总能学到东西。但我觉得我既学到了东西，又和一些新朋友变得更亲近了。所以我喜欢这样。所以是的，我们今天本来也要邀请一位嘉宾，但他们没有回复。
Admittedly, we sent them an email two days ago. So not. huge surprise. And then the last thing I'll mention to round out this episode is that a couple times over the last little bit, I've mentioned books. When we were talking to Mark Serafin back in July, which only released like a couple weeks ago because of the backlog that we were building up due to the kid being on the way. He recommended a bunch of books. And I since then have created an AI-Fi ranking for myself personally. I'm working through a ton of stuff. Right now, I just finished Neuromancer and I'm like through five of the eight or nine murder bot books,
诚然，我们两天前才给他们发了邮件。所以并不令人惊讶。最后，为了结束这一集，我想提一下，在过去的一段时间里，我提到了几次书。当我们七月份和 Mark Serafin 交谈时，由于孩子即将出生导致的积压，那期节目直到几周前才发布。他推荐了一堆书。从那时起，我为自己创建了一个科幻小说排名。我正在阅读大量的东西。现在，我刚读完《神经漫游者》，并且已经读完了八九本《杀手机器人》系列中的五本，
Okay, the first one was pretty good. Neuromancer hot take was terrible. But anyways, if people are interested and they have recommendations outside of the books that I've already read, I already got a couple via Twitter DMs and the GitHub discussions. Go check out that link and feel free to recommend shows or books. That concludes, I think this is going to be episode 306. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a
好吧，第一本还不错。《神经漫游者》的即时评价是太糟糕了。但无论如何，如果人们感兴趣，并且有我还没读过的书的推荐，我已经通过 Twitter 私信和 GitHub 讨论收到了一些推荐。去看看那个链接，欢迎推荐节目或书籍。我想这就是第306集了。请务必查看节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个
get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是‘混乱中撒点信息’。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。